The piracy paradox is a paradox related
to a fashion design.
Uh,
maybe related to other things,
but,
uh,
mostly related to fashion design.
The paradox arises from the following,
uh,
kind of puzzle,
which is we usually think of
intellectual property protection,
copyright,
for example,
as a necessary element for creative
production.
So writers won't,
right?
If they think there are books are just
going to be copied and musicians won't
create music if they think their works
or just could be stolen.
And so that's why Paris is such a
problem.
What's interesting about fashion design
is you see a lot of creativity in the
fashion world and yet there's no
protection for fashion designs.
So dress appears in the runway on the
Oscars and the next day,
two days later,
you can buy a cheap version of that from
a company like aps.
And so the privacy paradox is looks at
this puzzle and,
and,
and the idea is that unlike other
industries in which piracy seems to
drive out creativity in fashion,
it doesn't drive it out.
And in fact,
it seems to accelerate it.
And the reason is that copying of the
copying of designs as it spreads out
into the marketplace makes the original
buyer,
they were the early adopter of a
particular design,
want to then move on to something new,
right?
So fashion's always cycling.
And so one way to think about it is that
it accelerates the fashion cycle.
So it's paradoxical,
he helpful.
Couple of implications.
One is
that we probably,
that our understanding of what
creativity requires,
which is very instrumental,
one in the US legal system needs to be a
little more nuanced.
And so when we think of it as a public
policy question,
to what degree should government provide
these monopoly rights,
which is what copyrights and patents and
trademarks are.
Uh,
we need to think about how different
industries,
we need to be a little more industry
specific.
So rather than a blanket set of rules,
we want to,
we want to understand how these
industries work and what kinds of
inducements they need.
So right now there's a bill before
Congress to give fashion designers,
uh,
a kind of copyright.
And that's probably not necessary,
right?
So,
and there may be other cases in which
it's not necessary.
I think generally
very aggressive about intellectual
property in the U s we're quiet,
uh,
were quite eager to make sure that other
countries protect our intellectual
property.
And I think generally that's been
helpful to us.
Uh,
we are the major producer of movies or a
major producer of movies,
um,
lots of other entertainment industries,
software,
et cetera.
So,
so intellectual property is essential to
the American economy of the 21st
century.
And so we've been,
um,
understandably aggressive about
protecting it in that I think has been
good for our economy.
But it's not just an economic question,
right?
So one of the things that we ought to
think about when we're thinking about
how much protection should be given is
what should be in the public domain.
What,
what is,
um,
what should be allowed us fair use,
uh,
how much,
how long should the protection b and
there,
I think there's a fair question to be
asked about whether we have overshot
what is reasonable.
And so it's very difficult,
for example,
uh,
for musicians to sample other songs.
I'm more than,
you know,
tiny little snippets because the law has
made it extremely complex and cumbersome
and costly.
And so many people argue that we've kind
of gone well beyond what's reasonable
and made the public domain the domain of
things that we can all use and remix and
we create,
um,
really inaccessible in a way that's
probably not optimal.
Okay.
And he'd done a couple of things to get
around that.
One is in the World Trade Organization,
which countries like China are eager to
be a part of and they are in fact a
member.
We've made an electrical property part
of that agreement.
So a part of that organization.
So we have a set of Ip rules that every
member state of the WTO has to,
has to accept.
And that linkage between trade and Ip
has been very effective.
We do that in our bilateral trade
agreements as well.
We go and we say,
you want to trade agreement with us,
Peru or Columbia or whatever,
Australia,
great.
But you have to accept a set of
intellectual property rules and you have
to enforce them.
So,
um,
so we've used leverage against these
countries and,
um,
you know,
it's not perfect.
So China is still,
you can travel in Asia.
I was in Vietnam a few years ago and
pirated dvds are everywhere,
right?
So it's not,
it's not perfect.
Um,
but we've been cracking down,
uh,
in a way that we hadn't in the past.
And I think that has slowly moved to
these countries closer to our preferred
position.
It's had an enormous effect on piracy in
that anything that's digital is so music
downloading,
anything that's digital is incredibly
easy to copy.
And therefore,
uh,
the,
the piracy that goes on as is rampant.
So,
you know,
25 years ago you wanted to copy our
record,
you had a cassette tape,
it was complicated.
Now it's a click and you're done.
So technology has had an enormous effect
and that's what has driven a lot of the
concern within the u s over increasing
Ip protection and making sure that other
countries in the global marketplace have
the same sets of rules.
Um,
has technology been effective in
fighting it?
I suppose so,
but I'm not,
I can't say I can think of an example.
I think it's primarily been,
um,
uh,
you know,
been something that's made the piracy
problem larger.
On the other hand,
I think it's led to a certain kinds of
innovation and industry.
So when the VCR came out,
uh,
companies were very concerned.
It's going to be the end of the
television industry,
not the case at all.
Right?
So it ended up creating a whole new
industry.
Um,
you know,
itunes is now this enormous company,
uh,
or enormous enterprise from apple that
didn't exist.
So,
so change brings opportunity in every
economic domain.
And I think Ip is no different.
Again,
the question is how much,
how do you balance the incumbent
industries against these,
these unknown future things that we
can't,
we can't know or predict.